la hausse des prix maintenant dure
depuis cinq mois alors ça intéressant de
regarder cette progression a depuis le
mois de janvier ça a un impact vraiment
très sérieux sur le porte monnaie des
consommateurs puisque nilsen l'a évalué
à 90 euros qui serait partie d'ailleurs
en trois parties sur ces 90 euros y en
avait 27 pour les dépenses de carburant
donc c'est des dépenses supplémentaires
par rapport à une période normale 32
euros pour la facture énergie et puis 31
euros de dépenses alimentaires pour
l'instant je le répète 90 euros c'est la
hausse moyenne pour le porte monnaie des
français alors voilà il on est répartie
il a augmenté à sion ça va continuer
dans tous les domaines et oui ça va se
diffuser ça va se diffuser parce que
l'inflation en fait on peut le regarder
avec des chocs de prix comme vous avez
évoqué la sur les carburants sur
l'énergie sur l'alimentation mais
surtout il faut voir l'inflation comme
une mécanique avec une mécanique avec
des engrenages avec des éléments qui
s'enchaînent sauf que on n'a pas la
carte de cette mécanique préalablement
et en fait on sait jamais exactement où
vont s'arrêter les engrenages ce qu'il
faut regarder là il ya un point qui
n'est pas évoquée c'est ce qui est en
train d'augmenter actuellement ce sont
les prix des produits manufacturés
ce sont les prix des services igs moitié
papier ada triplé exactement vous soyez
donc on est en train de déborder d'une
inflation qui était très localisées sur
des chocs de prix de l'énergie vert à
une gamme beaucoup mais attend du monde
en général avec elle on expliquait que
l'inflation s'était en fait quand
l'offre était supérieur à la fin de nos
peines demandées sur l offre oui c'est
effectivement le cas en fait c'est on a
dans l'inflation un peu l'expression de
l'effet papillon si vous voulez ça il
faut aller chercher l'arbre des causes
d'où est partie cette inflation parce
que ça faisait des années que les
banques centrales
donc ceux qui gèrent la monnaie en
europe et aux états unis essayé de
ranimer l'inflation y avait passé
d'inflation on était sur une inflation
très basse mais en déclin sur même en
déflation d'akron et même en déflation
mais l'inflation c'est un peu comme du
ketchup si vous voulez vous secouer le
tube de ketchup il se passe rien
jusqu'au moment où ça se répand et on
est un peu dans cette période où on a
essayé de faire sortir le ketchup et
houba voilà maintenant il est venu en il
ya personne qui nous regardent il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont acquis ont
profité de avant la relation pour
emprunter à des taux défiant toute
concurrence on a emprunté à 0,8 à 0,9
alors est ce que ces gens là vont être
impactés où est ce qu'ils ont
on va pas leur changer leur soutien
d'aubry si le contrat et ces contrats
étaient
inférieures à
changer mais ceux qui ont justement
emprunté à 08 09 sont plutôt des gens
qui sont gagnants s'ils tentaient que
les revenus suivent les prix c'est la
mort de la question parce que si vous
avez les revenus qui vont suivre
l'inflation et c'est là que l'on passe
dans cet engrenage dans cette mécanique
inflationnistes il les revenus suivant
l'inflation alors à ce moment là bas
vous supporter un taux d'intérêt à 08 09
avec des revenus qui progresse de 3 4%
et bien vous êtes donc gagner aux
gagnants les perdants pour les gens qui
nous regardent pareil est ce que l'état
va indexer tout ce qui est smig
à l'inflation alors le smic est indexé
sur l'inflation c'était assez récent oui
mais en fait non c'est une règle dans
une règle mais c'est une règle toujours
automatique is automatique c'est
automatique à une indexation pour pour
le sucre d'ailleurs c'est le seul
salaire qui est indexée sur l'inflation
les autres à les autres c'est très cosy
phone à blanc celle-ci cyril hanouna
nous regarde par exemple lui dire qu'il
ya cette portion de la passion qu'il
faudrait un excellent aux non sa
nomination
non non pas obligés on aimait bien les
deux jurés dont les textes et ce qui se
pratique dans la réalité est en fait
comme vous regardez la manière dont se
fait l'inflation non ce sont les
évolutions de salaires c'est en réalité
une réaction allant à l'inflation qui
est constatée alors la conséquence de
natation c'est que les gens cessent ça
fait de consommer donc c'est un cercle
infernal sa cavale en consomme - alex
alors on a en effet cassé autre chose à
acheter bah oui mais on va regarder
et on va aller ce que les français ne
consomment plus c'était appels de balle
est regardé les français boudent surtout
le chocolat en tablette dont les achats
chute de plus de 10% les épices de 12%
mais aussi les pâtes avec -9% pour
limiter la flambée du prix de leurs
caddies les consommateurs achètent moins
un phénomène qui touche particulièrement
les foyers modestes qui sacrifie en
premier les achats d'alcool jusqu'à -15
% selon l'étude mais aussi les jus de
fruits - 10 % ou les poissons - 16%
alors les clients changent de magasins
pour faire leurs courses les enseignes
de 10 40 ont vu leur fréquentation
augmenter les français seraient aussi
sur les promotions elles représentent
désormais plus de 21% du chiffre
d'affaires de la grande île bution
contre 19% avant la fin de la crise
sanitaire enfin on va déjà des
conséquences directes sur la
consommation d'eau quelque part la
croissance passe en bout de piste géant
mais n'avait pas les moyens parce que si
on a plus de croissance
karim a effectivement c'est une
adaptation des comportements de sa vie a
été bien résumé c'est à dire que au lieu
d'acheter un produit bio et bien on va
acheter une marque de distributeurs par
exemple en produits alimentaires pour
des vêtements bien ça va être le
développement de ce qui était déjà en
cours le développement de la seconde
main le développement des vêtements
d'occasion enfin il ya tout un ensemble
de mécanismes qui vont se mettre en
place des adaptations de la part des
consommateurs mais qui in fine et où il
va se traduire par mois de consommation
et un peu moins de croissance oui on
n'arrête pas de justifier cette
inflation par la guerre en ukraine mais
ce qu'au final la guerre en ukraine n'a
pas bon dos et que ça profite pas aux
industriels qui en profitent peut-être
pour augmenter les prix de manière
exponentielle alors que les matières
premières n'augmente pas forcément à
tout le blé augmente non mais pas tous
prêts à aider à réagir et partiale et
voilà les ombres avant-dernière ça vous
mangez l'art de manière exponentielle
alors que c'est laid les matières
premières ont augmenté elles exactement
la guerre en ukraine est un
amplificateur d'un mouvement qui étaient
déjà là quand vous regardez le cours du
blé il n'a pas attendu le conflit en
ukraine pour flamber mais et c'est là
que justement revient un peu sur surtout
les enchaînements qui se sont mis en
place depuis quand un peu oublié qu'on
sort d'une période assez exceptionnel
qui s'est appelé le covilha période de
confinement pendant laquelle on a mis
l'économie à l'arrêt et donc c'est vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure les
déséquilibre entre offre et demande et
bien c'est exactement ce que l'on a vécu
on a eu un net déséquilibre qui a été
très important entre la capacité à
produire parce que les gens étaient chez
eux ne pouvaient pas n'était pas en
capacité de produire et puis une demande
qui a été préservé une demande l'année
dernière enfin pardon en 2020 l'activité
a reculé de 7% mais le revenu des
ménages a progressé donc ça veut dire
que la production était en retrait mais
la capacité à dépenser était encore là
avaient été préservés donc au bout d'un
moment ça
expliqué que beaucoup de français
avaient profité du comic pour épargner
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup qu'il y avait
une vraie réserve d'argent donc une
réserve de croissance oui tout à fait
alors est ce que cette réserve d'argent
vient dans le circuit a priori non pas
encore ça n'est pas le cas ou alors si
elle revient dans le circuit elle
revient sous une forme contraintes
justement pour faire face à la hausse
des prix et non pas prêts à augmenter
les achats ce qui fait la croissance et
par l'évolution du prix ce qui fait la
croissance et la con idée de ce que l'on
va acheter mais l' onu en nous on tape
dans les palois
ça concerne tout la viande surgelée +18
l'énergie doit +15 la viande hachée +14
pas de pizza externe pas briser +12
farine plus trop bon tout ça est
derrière elle et orateur ça c'est
terrible parce que enfin moi j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup d'amis restaurateurs
qui disait que maintenant pour souvenir
c'était absolument terrible et vraiment
ça coûtait deux à trois fois plus cher
et que du coup ils étaient obligés
d'exercer les prix beaucoup plus élevé
donc voilà même pour les vacanciers
c'est terrible parce que l'avion coûte
trois fois plus cher c'est c'est fou
enfin imaginer sa famille mais il a dit
c'est les gars tschopp en fait certains
de se diffuser partout où on va le voir
même pour le prix de l'eau le prix de
l'eau à la halle aux a priori on pouvait
pas penser que sa dette à pâté et basse
et regarder et le produit le plus vendu
en supermarché la bouteille d'eau la
moins chère aussi mais cristalline va
augmenter ses prix + 10 % une eau à bas
coût dont le prix n'avaient pas bougé
depuis près de 20 ans alors pourquoi une
telle augmentation
d'abord ces petites billes de plastique
qui valent aujourd'hui de l'or matières
indispensables pour fabriquer les
bouteilles le prix du plastique flambe +
39 % à l'automne dernier autre raison
avec la hausse des prix du carburant
transporter la marchandise coûte
forcément plus cher à l'entreprise
elle va donc répercuter ces coûts sur
les distributeurs donc la bresse et
palau qui augmente c'est le plastique et
oui vous savez pareil pour les pour la
rentrée les stylos bille en plastique
les cahiers classe c'est du papier donc
ça a flambé donc ça va se répandre
partout est ce qu'à un secteur où des
produits qui vont pas être affecté c'est
difficile à apprécier et parce que il y
à différentes mécanismes qui vont jouer
non ils sont bien résumé c'est
effectivement le prix de la matière
première qui va induire une répercussion
de la part de l'industriel dans les prix
mais vous avez d'autres activités ne
faut pas oublier que la moitié de ce que
les ménages consomment en fait ce qu'on
quand on regarde la composition d'un
budget des ménages à moitié de ce que
l'on consomme ce sont des services c'est
des assurances c'est le loyer c'est le
coiffeur c'est des frais bancaires que
l'on parle tous les abonnements que l'on
prend et donc a priori il n'y a pas
beaucoup de matières premières de dents
et bien en fait les évolutions de prix
vont concerner aussi ce type de ce type
de service ce type de produits parce
qu'ils vont réagir beaucoup plus à
l'augmentation des salaires qui elle
même vient en réaction à l'inflation qui
s'est installée sur les matières
proposées vous avez vraiment les
corriger d'augmenter les salaires vous
avez dit à part le smic est acquis et
qui est indexé oui donc c'est passé pas
obligatoire ça non mais alors justement
ce qu'ils font regarder dans ce cas ce
sont les autres évolutions de salaires
et vous avez notamment ceux que l'on
appelle les minima de branche les minima
de branche ce qui vient de la
négociation qui se fait dans les
entreprises et les aide dans les rangs
professionnels avec les syndicats le
minima de branche et progresse de 3% au
premier trimestre 3 % c'est une
progression que l'on n'avait jamais vu
par le passé et surtout les minima de
branche ils réagissent en fonction de
l'inflation qui a été constaté c'est à
dire passer en général ça se fait ces
négociations elles se font à la fin de
l'année donc à la fin de l'année
dernière on avait 3 % en inflation il ya
eu 3 % d'augmentation des minima de
branche là on est à 5% cette
5,200 ça dépend de l'indicateur je
voulais c'est 0,5
oui on peut les partager mais on va être
peut-être 5% la fin de l'année à la fin
de l'année 2022 et donc les prochaines
négociations de branche risque de faire
sur un niveau de saine alors cocorico on
est les meilleurs pour l'instant dans la
gestion des stations
européens l'allemagne et des est devant
nous les étals et l'espagne deux aussi
pareil on est les meilleurs pour deux
raisons principales cela tient notre mix
énergétique à la fin l'énergie que l'on
utilisé on a plutôt plus d'électricité
est plutôt de l'électricité nucléaire
que les autres pays européens qui
dépendent plus du gaz et du pétrole et
donc le prix du gaz du pétrole à plus
flambé que ne l'a fait le prix de
l'électricité même si la montée donc ça
c'est l'aspect mix énergétique mais
surtout on est beaucoup plus intervenu
en termes de finances publiques à
maîtriser pour maîtriser les prix c'est
notamment ben alors le plafond qui est
émis au prix du gaz dès le mois
d'octobre ça a été également les 18
centimes alors sur les héritiers des
gens qui ont qui ont expliqué après
c'est vrai que cette politique où l'état
met de l'argent et trouve des milliards
partout maintenant c'est incroyable
c'est qu'il faut un milliard il ya un
milliard là et il semblerait que
l'inflation arrange l'état français
puisque au final 6 à 5 6 10 15 %
d'inflation dans 10 ou 15 ans la dette
elle a disparu c'est vrai ou pas ça
alors ça va la réduire en tout cas est
ce que c'est vrai elle c'est pas aussi
facile que ça parce que déjà
ils s'en foutent pas ce qu'il y ait la
plaza va régler la dette mais alors
pourquoi on éradique totalement la dette
il faudrait que l'on à une inflation aux
10-15 % pendant plusieurs années et si
vous avez eu l'impression qui a installé
à ce rythme là en fait vous créer des
foyers de tension sociale absolument
incroyable parce que qu'est ce que
révèle in fine et l'inflation lignes
fines et c'est la valeur de la monnaie
or si vous avez une fuite si vous avez
une augmentation du prix advitam eternam
vous ne croyez plus en la valeur de la
monnaie et c'est ce qui fait le lien
social premier qui ait la confiance qui
est sacralisé dans la monnaie qui
commence à se dresser les fameuses
images en tant qu'équipe et leurs
baguettes avec des brouettes pendant la
guerre a juste on va regarder ou payet
de l'impact sur les français il ya des
français qui sont en véritable détresse
regardez au début je faisais un panier
de courses pour environ 40 50 euros pour
la semaine et là on est passé sur du
minimum 60 euros 70 euros on pourra une
semaine ça fait beaucoup je suis
désespéré parce que du coup on essaie de
trouver des solutions pour payer moins
cher essayez de dépenser moins d'argent
possible
effectivement donc on est obligé de se
priver sur certains trucs donc pas de
sorties fades restaurant est patent
payant alors nous on a la chance d'être
premier mais est ce qu est ce que vous
vous dans chroniqueur cette hausse là
vous là que vous commencez à la à le
ressentir moi je vous avoue le punch
scooter maintenance et remballe ses 10
balles de plus en espèces de la voiture
aussi non moi ça me fait beaucoup de
peine d'entendre ça moi je trouve cette
dame ça me touche énormément moi je
crois qu'il faudrait faire un effort
national la voyez par exemple quelques
exemples les distributeurs les les
grands magasins ils devraient réduire
leurs marges pendant une période donnée
si vous voulez les banques pareil les
frais bancaires ils sont trop élevés les
frais bancaires c'est honteux il faut
dépenser déjà un effort national est que
toutes ces personnes là nous aident à
aide les français vous pensez que c'est
possible ce genre de chose
mais bon sang quand même
[Musique]
mais il faut connaît il faut voir dans
ce cas l'évolution du coût de l'ensemble
en fin de 2 tout ce que les banques
elles mêmes vont avoir en augmentation
du coût notamment pour des raisons de
salaire parce que les salaires forme une
composante importante des coûts
d'exploitation de la banque et donc
c'est un équilibre qui est à trouver oui
bien sûr on peut demander une réduire
l'effet 3d mal jusqu'au moment où on
peut aller aussi jusqu'à l'idée du
blocage des prix mais bernard mais je
vous aime beaucoup mais les frais
bancaires s'est pas l'essentiel ce qu'il
faudrait qu'ils ont payée moins cher
pour les fritures et toute escapade à
être sonné mais aux banques c'est à zéro
ce qui va pas c'est qu'on nous dit que
c'est la crise partout or c'est pas vrai
parce que ce qui est paradoxal c'est
qu'il ya plein de gens ont des millions
de français qui galèrent et de l'autre
côté il ya plein d'entreprises de grands
groupes dont les bénéfices augmentent
chaque année de quoi est-ce qu'on peut
pas forcer ces entreprises à augmenter
et non pas les minima et tous les
salaires proportionnellement à
l'inflation c'est ça la solution aussi
ce cap l'inde entreprises qui augmentent
leurs bénéfices et ça personne ne dit
s'il ya des gens qui le disent dans le
débat politique aimerait quand même
quelques uns qui a grillé antoine
septième alors justement il faut
regarder comment évoluent relativement
les prix des approvisionnements de
l'ensemble des entreprises par rapport à
leur prix de vente ce que l'on voit
jusqu'à présent c'est que l'augmentation
des prix de vente donc ce qui sort des
usines ce qui sort de la fabrique d'une
entreprise cette augmentation des prix
de vente est moindre que ne l'est
l'augmentation des prix des
approvisionnements donc il ya déjà un
peu de pincement les marges il
s'effectue après on peut discuter de
l'ampleur du mécanisme mais jusqu'à
présent ce que l'on voit tout ce qu'il
ya plutôt un amaigrissement des vous
vous êtes chef d'entreprise oui est ce
que vous allez augmenter les salaires si
mes bénéfices augmentent oui bien sûr
mais ce n'est pas le cas mais oui sinon
même blague à part les bénéfices restent
de manière exponentielle chaque année et
on est on dit aux gens il ya plus
d'argent et plus d'argent c'est pas vrai
quand vous avez un bénéfice de plus 100
% + 50 % m/m +10 % et que l'inflation
est de 5 ou 7 % il faut augmenter les
gens de manière proportionnelle ça me
paraît évident magali garde à vous êtes
chef d'entreprise également est ce que
vous allez monter des salaires à moi
tout ce qui est gestion je m'inquiète
pas bien sur
la question un salarié vient vous voir
dit voilà chers à monsieur m'a donné à
moi s'il fait gagne de l'argent j'ai
enfin gagné attendez
on ajoute un game me suis rendu compte
que dépenser 90 euros de plus par mois
c'est concrètement aussi été calculée à
ses 90 ans ça dépend pour s'avancer dire
beaucoup plus je voudrais compter 200
euros de plus par mois si ma société peu
et je vois que moi aussi fin que j'ai de
la marge du oui évidemment je vais pas
lui enlever ça en vaut le pauvre non
merci
j'ai compris vous avez dans son
porte-monnaie salue on est quand même
parce que les dépenses donc moi si mon
entreprise et bénéfices et son bénéfice
mais je n'ai pas le poème a rajouté 100
euros sur un salaire stable ou du monde
100 euros pour une entreprise qui fait
du bénéfice de ralentir d'accord donc
retrouvé mon fils et ma belle fille qui
bosse chez vous
d'avis bizarrement tous les jours irak
le train le matin oh non oui oui oui
deux heures par jour il est au taquet
concrètement est ce que il peut avoir un
espoir est ce que alors par les ponts
besoin est ce qu'on est une façon qui
est la structure structurelles ou
conjoncturelles ronde est ce que ça va
perdurer ou est-ce que ça va disparaître
avec la fin de la guerre en ukraine avec
voilà les mesures des uns et des autres
avec l'europe qui pourrait peut-être
pour une fois travailler ensemble alors
il ya certains des éléments qui vont
disparaître ce qui a fait que
l'inflation est revenue c'est parce
qu'on a eu des pénuries qui ont été
locales qui se sont manifestés qui ont
amorcé la pompe qui en ont commencé à
donner la mécanique inflationnistes de
fait on est passés d'ores et déjà dans
la dans le moment où cette mécanique est
installé où les hausses de prix
occasionne des hausses de coûts les
hausses de coûts vont occasionner à leur
tour la commanderie par le dos et
ceinturée voilà donc voilà on est en
train de passer sur des éléments
structurels et parmi les éléments
structurels il ya d'autres dont deux
éléments qui sont beaucoup plus lourds
c'est que pendant très longtemps il très
peu d'inflation pour une raison très
simple c'est que on utilisait beaucoup
la mondialisation on allait
s'approvisionner dans les pays en
fonction des bassins a vu avec les
masques et là on a vu avec les masques
on a vu les problèmes de souveraineté
que cela posait et on a en train quand
même d'avoir plutôt en mécanique inverse
et donc la relocalisation c'est plutôt
quelque chose qui va être permissif et
c'est un mauvais signe pour l'économie
du pays oui mais il faudra être prêt
c'est à dire qu'on est toujours un peu
schizophrène c'est à dire que on est
consommateur enfin on se pense
producteurs mais on est aussi
consommateurs et
solution c'est de m'ordonner de magasins
comptait gaspille on va regarder des
images à chaque passage au supermarché
il faut tenter de limiter le budget
courses la date de péremption arrive
bientôt certains magasins pas de luz le
prix ça fait d euros d euros qu on
dépense plus quoi pour respecter son
budget mensuel caroline surveille les
bonnes affaires avant même de se rendre
au supermarché elle planifie les repas
de la semaine en fonction des promotions
en magasin et une fois le repas terminé
pas question de mettre les restes à la
poubelle tout et conserver soigneusement
au frigo on essaye de rien jeter ça
honnêtement on a vraiment progressé dans
ce domaine là des repas tout prêts
faciles à réchauffer sur les pause du
midi de quoi gagner du temps et éviter
le gaspillage à canto est un cépage gêne
c'est que on dit que la solution c'est
la solidarité globalement oui on s'en
sortir pour limiter l'inflation en tout
cas c'est de la sobriété c'est
effectivement un usage qui est beaucoup
plus raisonnée il ya déjà une part de ce
qui est très bien évoqué là une
dimension de chasse au gaspi est quand
même assez assez importante c'est une
manière de préserver son pouvoir d'achat
et je pense que c'est l'inflation ça
amène dossier de la responsabilisation
individuelle alors on a beaucoup parlé
de la gare en ukraine mais certains
économistes historiens de vous explique
que en fait derrière la guerre est
toujours une forte croissance et où ça
va disparaître après la fin de la guerre
en en ukraine oui on peut toujours
espérer sar va y aurait peut-être une
forte croissance en ukraine pour
reconstruire ses démons celui
de
destructeur de croissance quinquin qu'un
réalisateur de croissance donc peut-être
qu'on peut espérer après mais désigné
déjà le moment dur qui est un passé qui
est celui que le couple a eu deux encore
oui à peu près 12 ans alors là le
simuler le prix des carburants va va pas
forcément un nouveau augmenté il a
franchi une marche d'escalier majeur
mais il risque de rester élevé pendant
un an